bonjour à tous donc jean quatremer
journaliste à libération comme vous
l'expliqué ce fait 25 ans que je couvre
l'europe et on m'a donné un sujet qui
est totalement impossible c'est à dire à
quoi ressemblera l'europe dans 20 ans
franchement je n'en sais rien je suis
pas voyante je ne tire pas les cartes
il est extrêmement difficile de tirer
des prévisions donc des faits qui sont
forcément inconnu à partir de faits
connus alors la seule chose qu'on peut
faire c'est on énumère des faits connus
et on essaye de prévoir à partir de ces
faits connus aujourd'hui qui peuvent
changer dès demain ou dès après demain
les lignes d'évolution les plus
probables
alors quand on parle d'europe je pense
que la première chose à faire c'est
d'abandonner tout ce que on vous a
appris tout ce que l'on croit sur
l'europe parce que l'europe c'est pas du
tout une europe des peuples dont on vous
parle en permanence on est là l'europe
des peuples erasmus les voyages des
choses comme ça aurait été l'europe
c'est une europe des états il faut
abandonner cette idée que ce sont les
peuples qui ont voulu l'europe l'europe
n'a jamais été voulu par les peuples
au lendemain de la seconde guerre
mondiale en 1950 quand on lance la
construction communautaire à ce moment
là est ce que vous croyez
alors que les peuples l'europe ait été
détruite par une guerre absolument
monstrueuse qu'il ya vu un génocide
entre 1945 et 1950 il ya eu des
déplacements massifs de populations à
travers l'europe les gens mouraient
encore de faim mourey de froid la france
était encore détruite je ne parle même
pas des pays de l'est sous l'a carrément
intérêts strictement plus rien
l'allemagne avait été détruite par les
alliés puisqu'elle avait résisté
jusqu'au bout
est ce que vous croyez qu'à ce moment là
la préoccupation centrale des peuples
c'était de penser à l'europe
évidemment pas la préoccupation centrale
des peuples à ce moment là c'était de
penser à la survie quotidienne et il a
fallu quelques hommes une élite une
toute petite élite qui se disent mais
comment on peut faire pour éviter que la
catastrophe qu'on vient de connaître en
1939 1945 qui a répété la catastrophe de
14-18 se répète à nouveau
donc voilà c'est un projet qui a été
porté par quelques-uns donc les français
les allemands les italiens puis les pays
du benelux pays bas belgique et
luxembourg
cette petite élite s'est réuni autour
d'une table en disant qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire pour éviter que ça recommence
et l'idée ça a été de construire
l'europe on la construit vous le savez
la communauté économique du charbon et
de l'acier cd rom était en commun la
gestion du charbon et de l'acier qui
permettait de fabriquer des armes
et puis ensuite on a fait le grand
marché donc la communauté économique
européenne
mais à chaque fois c'est traité ont été
négociés par des élites voulue par des
élites et ça a été adoptée non pas par
référendum mais par les parlements donc
composé de députés représentant les
peuples et honnêtement les peuples c'est
en 1957 vous aviez questionner les
peuples pour savoir ce qu'était l'europe
les gens dieu bron oui c'est le charbon
et l'acier éventuellement à partir des
années 60 c'est l'agriculture mais ils
n'étaient pas prêts plus préoccupée que
cela est ce que les choses ont
fondamentalement changé aujourd'hui
évidemment pas est-ce que vous avez vu
des grandes manifestations à travers
l'europe pour défendre l'idée européenne
est ce que vous voyez des peuples
angoissés des citoyens angoissé face à
l'avenir de l'europe rue une petite
minorité mais la plupart des gens ne
s'en préoccupe pas la majorité des gens
se sentent d'abord national et ensuite
éventuellement européens voire citoyen
du monde
l'europe ça reste une affaire d'état une
affaire délit alors c'est très important
ce que je suis en train de vous dire
parce que comme ce sont les états qui
ont décidé de faire quelque chose qu'on
n'avait jamais fait jusqu'à présent
c'est à dire de partager la souveraineté
une partie de notre souveraineté
volontairement avec d'autres états
jusqu'à présent ce qui avait été fait
c'était des empires uniquement des
empires c'est à dire il y avait un état
qui conquérait les autres états qui
imposait sa langue sa culture son
système économique
son système juridique cette fois ci il
fallait trouver un donc un point
d'équilibré entre des états qui avaient
des traditions historiques juridiques
économiques et c'est totalement
différente et qu'il fallait il fallait
donc construire des flambées construire
des institutions dans lesquelles les
états se retrouvent et que les compromis
qui serait élaborée par ces institutions
ne lèsent véritablement personnes c'est
à dire que personne ne gagne mais
personne ne perd non plus
c'était sale important dans la
construction communautaire et surtout
les états se méfiant les uns des autres
voulaient garder le contrôle absolu et
ont toujours cherché à garder le
contrôle absolu des institutions
communautaires qu'il crée c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui quand on vous parle
d'europe
vous n'y comprenez strictement rien et
franchement je sais pas vous en vouloir
parce que moi même après 25 ans à
m'occuper d'affaires européennes je me
perds encore parce que il faut le
principe de toute la construction
communautaire c'est comment les états
peuvent le contrôler l'origine des lois
communautaires parce que l'europe c'est
une c est essentiellement un producteur
de normes et à l'arrivée commence à ces
normes sont appliquées dans les
différents états les états sont si vous
voulez la main de dieu this on le
principe d'origine et le principe de
réception à chaque fois donc ils
contrôlent l'ensemble les institutions
c'est pas du tout les états unis
d'europe
c'est pas vous n'avez pas un président
américain un président européen vous
avez passé n'existe pas vous n'avez pas
celle-là des états vous avez un vague
parlement européen qui ressemble un peu
à la chambre des représentants
américains mais le parlement européen
n'est pas la chambre des représentants
hier il suffit de regarder comment sont
élus les les députés européens
c'est dans le cas de circonscription
nationale et les les petits les
représentants enfin les citoyens des
petits états pèsent jusqu'à 12 fois plus
que les représentants des grands états
par exemple il faut 850 4000 français
pour élire un député alors qu'il ne faut
que 72 mines maltais pour élire un
député c'est à dire c'est la négation du
principe fondateur de toute démocratie
un homme égale une voix celle ci qu elle
se comprend que si on a dans la tête que
ce sont les états qui en réalité envoie
des représentants des citoyens siéger au
parlement européen
et ce sont les états qui sont les
maîtres de la compétence qu'on appelle
la compétence de la compétence à dire
c'est eux qui décident à chaque instant
ce qui va passer dans la machine
communautaire si vous me posez la
question mais j'en sais quoi au fond les
compétences de l'union européenne de
quoi s'occupe l'union européenne alors
j'ai une vague idée c'est à dire que je
sais qu'il ya cinq compétences
exclusives mais pour le reste dont la
politique monétaire par exemple la
politique de concurrence
lapret la préservation des ressources
halieutiques halieutiques c'est quoi
c'est la mère évidemment les poissons se
c'est absolument essentiel
donc ça c'est les presses et ces choses
dont s'occupe l'union européenne seuls
mais pour le reste on n'en sait rien
parce que ce sont ce qu'on appelle des
compétences partagées
c'est à dire que les états peuvent
décider à l'unanimité au sein du conseil
européen des chefs d'état de
gouvernement de faire passer un certain
nombre de domaines dans la machine
communautaire donc les compétences de
l'union européenne passent leur temps à
varier en fonction des intérêts des
états alors quand on la salsa en tête
c'est à dire qu'au fond ce sont les
états qui contrôle la machinerie
communautaire donc l'évolution possible
de l'union européenne on doit interroger
non pas les peuples se dire qu'est ce
qui est possible avec les peuples monde
mais que ce que veulent les états donc
il faut s'adresser aux états et pour
faire évoluer l'union européenne pour
qu'elle change
comme ce sont les états qui sont les
maîtres delà de la compétence et qui
sont les maîtres des traités il faut
donc que les états acceptent à
l'unanimité de modifier les règles du
jeu vous imaginez s'il fallait
l'unanimité des français de limiter des
britanniques dynamité des belges pour
modifier la constitution
eh bien les évolutions se ferait
extrêmement lentement
c'est pour ça que l'europe évolué
extrêmement lentement à coups de
compromis extrêmement souvent tordu
insatisfaisant dans lesquels beaucoup ne
se retrouvent pas mais encore une fois
dans lesquelles personne n'a le
sentiment de perdre véritablement une
partie 2 de sons de son je dirais de sa
souveraineté ou ses intérêts nationaux
serait totalement compromis une fois que
vous avez ça en tête
comment peut évoluer l'union européenne
mais il faudrait alors moi mon rêve
c'est une europe fédérale c'est à dire
on bâtit les états unis d'europe à
l'américaine avec un président européen
élu un sénat une chambre des
représentants des compétences
souveraines extrêmement précises dans
des domaines dans lesquels l'union
européenne aujourd'hui n'a aucune
compétence la défense la politique
étrangère la politique d'immigration la
politique d'asile etc
c'est à dire en fait de compétence
souveraine ce qui fait un état si lui
fait une puissance européenne
c'est ce qui se passe aux etats-unis
vous avez un président américain élu
avec il dispose des forces armées qui
décide qui entrent sur le territoire
américain qui n'entrent pas la politique
d'immigration
la politique de naturalisation donc la
nationalité etc
donc ça serait mon rêve mais ça voudrait
dire que les états en fait renonce au
contrôle de des institutions
communautaires c'est à dire on renonce
au contrôle de de l'union européenne
et ça le problème et c'est là la grande
déception c'est que ça n'arrivera pas ça
n'arrivera que si vous les citoyens vous
vous emparez de l'europe et vous obliger
les états à faire ce grand saut fédéral
donc l'évolution la plus probable
hélas hélas hélas de l'union européenne
et j'en souffre encore une forme donc
fédéraliste européen
c'est que on risque d'avoir je dirais la
continuation de ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui c'est à dire quelque chose
de complexe de brumeux où on ne sait pas
qui exercent véritablement la
responsabilité ou les états quand ils
rentrent chez eux les chefs de
gouvernement quand ils rentrent chez eux
disent on c'est pas moi qui ai dit c'est
des sas et bruxelles ont ça marche pas
c'est la faute à bruxelles même si tout
ça est un mensonge
donc ce système dans lequel personnes se
retrouvent personne ne se sent
représenter risque de perdurer avec des
améliorations évidemment parce que les
améliorations on y sera contraint de les
faire tout simplement à cause du choc
des crises extérieures
ce qui vient de se passer par exemple
avec la crise de la zone euro bah ça
nous a contraints a par exemple créé
alors ces techniques je le reconnais
l'union bancaire ça veut dire quoi c'est
à dire que les banques au lieu d'être
contrôlés par les états et par les
banques centrales nationales sont
contrôlés directement par francfort et
la banque centrale européenne
vous allez dire ouais c'était qui non
c'est très important parce que les
banques et les gouvernements couchent
ensemble ce sont les mêmes qui les
dirigent
et donc c'est pour ça que il ya eu
beaucoup de faillites bancaires parce
qu'en fait on se protège les uns les
autres briques maintenant si vous avez
un système bancaire qui est contrôlée
par une autorité extérieure et fédéral
vous avez une chance que la crise de
2007 2008 ne se reproduise pas c'est un
progrès certes technique mais c'en est
un est ce que demain par exemple on aura
une défense européenne
je n'y crois pas trop tout simplement
parce que ça voudrait dire que les
français qui resteront la seule défense
crédible dans l'union européenne puisque
les britanniques s'en vont et ça on le
regrettera pas et donc c'est plus que
les britanniques s'en vont eh bien ça
ça va être difficile pour les français
d'accepter que l'intervention de son
armée soit décidée par 27 pays en plus
ça voudra dire que des pays qui ont des
traditions pacifistes qui refusent
d'aller se battre acceptent d'aller
d'envoyer des hommes pour mourir sur des
théâtres extérieurs
parce qu'aujourd'hui la majorité de la
population européenne considère que
faire la guerre et mourir pour défendre
ses intérêts nationaux les intérêts
européens en l'occurrence
eh bien ça fait pas partie d'un avenir
je dirais souhaitable et prévisible
et pourtant on doit se dire que si on
veut défendre nos intérêts un jour il
faudra aller faire la guerre on vit pas
dans un monde de mickey on vit pas à
disneyland
il faudra bien se battre et le problème
c'est encore une fois c'est que pour
faire cette défense européenne crédible
ça veut dire que 1 la france renonce à
sa souveraineté mais ça veut dire aussi
que les autres pays acceptent d'envoyer
des jeunes mourir sur le fond oui parce
que sont les jeunes qui vont mourir
c'est rarement les vieux les gens de mon
âge qui vont mourir sur le front nous on
envoie les jeunes en règle générale donc
voilà ça risque d'être des dettes de
leur prise de continuer comme ça nous à
dire claudiquant dans un monde dans un
monde qui hélas devient de plus en plus
complexes où nous pesons de moins en
moins aujourd'hui l'europe c'est 500
millions de personnes dans un monde de 7
milliards d'habitants dans vingt ans ça
sera encore un monde de sans doute 8 9
10 milliards d'habitants et nous nous
poserons de moins en moins si nous nous
je terminerai sur cette phrase si nous
n'arrivons pas à nous unir et bien une
disparaîtront de l'histoire de
l'humanité
merci
[Applaudissements]